[Music]
but you are about to see is inspired by
true events near reading also is there a
bigger cop-out than inspired by true
events not based on a true story
not these events are entirely fictional
pick a fucking lane movie on the night
of February 11th 2005 movie starts off
feeling more like an ID discovery
special than an actual movie also if the
movie is going to blatantly rip off the
opening narration of the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre couldn't they just go all in
and get John Larroquette to do the
voiceover was he too busy filming them
at bride reunion special
according to the FBI there were an
estimated one point four million violent
crimes in America each year and at least
38 percent of them are mask based as you
are about to see damn this movie has
more text preamble than a pink Star Wars
movie I know Jordans freaked out and all
but this is the least helpful 9-1-1 call
ever pronoun game non sequiturs and
unanswered questions about Liv kryla
Jesus this movie as long as Vaughn tree
ring some dog b95 with the solemn
opening this is a horror movie or a
sequel to Dogville what he follows the
sinister rule of horror movie characters
that choose to stand in total darkness
instead of turning on the fucking lights
why did you do all this
the fact that this movie sets up a
tremendous amount of beautiful
exposition with zero dialogue for five
minutes at the beginning hammers home
that the opening narration was really
unnecessary so I'm gonna sin that again
I know James had planned a super
romantic evening at all but where did he
get this number of candles to surround
the tub eating your feelings cliche when
did Kristen light this cigarette we see
the setup of the pack being placed on
the table but there's no time that any
of those scripts are lit up and if never
seen again in the scene dude how many
bottles of champagne did you mean for
tonight sure it was supposed to be a
celebration of your love and shit but
it's starting to feel like you were
actively planning to get Kristen drunk
to make this proposal formal okay the
shaky-cam aesthetic works in theory for
this difficult conversation but it's so
goddamn shaky that I feel like I'm
having a stroke while watching it
this ain't the fucking Bourne Identity
dude get a fucking Steadicam content to
let you assume that James is sad and
lonely movie hammers it over your head
with a hyper literal Wilco song Fifty
Shades speed men also how do these
assholes not know that they're in a
horror movie having sex in a secluded
location with no security system
nah walking is tamra here movies biggest
sin might be that we never find out who
the hell Tamara is although since gamma
ward plays doll face here and Tamara and
Pirates of the Caribbean on Stranger
Tides this could mean the strangers is
part of the P otc universe if James
suspected this was the issue with the
light why didn't he try this when the
girl was on the front porch after he
haplessly flicked the switch also there
are two porch lights so why did fixing
one of them get both working so are they
just gonna leave that fucking ice cream
out all night like it's probably already
soup at this point and that's Bluebell
not some rinky-dink grocery store Brant
dammit I know you're upset but show some
fucking respect to the Bell Kristen
clearly places the needle on the record
at the beginning and we hear the opening
chords of joanna newsom as the sprout in
the bean but this is not the opening
track of any of her records geez Luke
Tyler holds a beer like she's a fucking
cowboy at a saloon the strangers
conveniently pick a house with a front
door that possesses neither a people nor
surrounding windows to be spotted prior
to opening it yeah but that shouldn't
stop it from beeping right that fucking
thing's on a battery will you just stay
on the phone with me James Wow the
masked assholes have perfect timing to
cut the phone line even though there's
no way they'd be able to hear what
Kristen's saying I guess the power of
nicotine addiction is greater than the
power of figuring out why the phone was
randomly cut off during a discussion
about a potential threat right outside
the door damn it that ice cream is still
sitting out granted this shot is
creepiest but what's the mask guys plan
here if Kristen does see him I thought
he and his crew got their jollies off by
intimidating and scaring their prey if
she turns a little as left movies over
apparently part of the plan to be super
creepy involves picking up the SH that
Kristen leaves on the floor ah
jumpscares stop it
you just gave us a much creepier visual
a few minutes ago dammit you're better
than this movie hate jump-scares
Kristen didn't get anywhere near the
record player to make it start again but
it clearly has a dramatic sense of time
there were at least two of the strangers
out there running all around the
property and banging on mere seconds
before James get back in the house how
did he not see any of them he's wearing
masks yeah but what about the other girl
at the front door
maybe the guy in the back was more
terrifying but it would be extremely
useful information to tell James that
there's more than one of these assholes
before he goes to hunt them
nobody can but Kristen said they were at
the door she didn't say they were in the
house yet dickhole
I mean it's James literally looking
everywhere except the fucking front and
back doors also I guess there is no
reason to turn on an overhead light
during this search she's there who knows
how many windows in this fucking house
but doll-faced happens to be standing in
view of the exact one Kristen chooses to
look out this exact moment costs
actually she looks like a girl with a
mask on and nothing like a ghost between
this comment and the act of looking
behind the boxes in the garage when
Kristen clearly tells James the people
have been outside banging on the windows
it's starting to make sense why Kristen
turned down the proposal one of them
came in here and took my phone Kristen
though what did James turn into such a
disbelieving fuck Kristen's statement
about her phone being taken is easily
provable at least one of these killers
went full on Carrie Underwood on James's
car but they didn't hear any of it when
they were searching the house this is
super creepy but entirely impossible
that James would not see the culprit in
the time it takes him to turn around one
minute and seven seconds of speed when
walking followed by 23 seconds of
Speedman staring this movie's tagline
should have been more Speedman than you
can handle
why would James use his tie to treat
Kristen's hand instead of like any of
the towels that are in the house or even
one of the napkins that are in very
close proximity yeah I haven't had a dog
bark karpass first off it's after four
o'clock in the fucking morning so I
wouldn't expect a bunch of traffic
second what does this prove did the
strangers kill all the pets in this
neighborhood they obviously didn't put
up roadblocks considering James was able
to run out and get cigarettes wow that
crapped it pinup-girl even know they
were backing out of the driveway at this
time they didn't have any lights on and
they were making very little noise and
she clearly had to come around a corner
with the truck so she couldn't see them
get out of the car get out of the car
just drive around the truck dumbass
whatever the strangers are throwing here
is heavy enough for a series of massive
jump scares but not heavy enough to
break the window have they tested the
substance before Jesus Christ I know the
strangers love and with people before
they eventually kill them but why what
they taste better if they're properly
scared because cops tend to show up when
no one has called them despite seeing
all this damage and just being shot at
Mike walks right back up to the house
instead of calling the cops first hello
Jimmy
Kristen probably would have been super
helpful if Mike kept calling out their
names once the other's house hello James
clearly isn't a fan if it's always sunny
in philadelphia I know James called Mike
earlier and it's always nice to see
Glenn Howerton show up but the Mike
character is clearly written solely
because the movie wants another dead
body you take the Mike scene out and
nothing changes there's an already
welcomed barn I'm gonna try and call for
help
this house has everything you need and
the most inconvenient places possible
it's as if it was constructed
specifically for a horror movie
Wow The Strangers got their really
specific graffiti up quickly also how
did they know that James would go out
this way after he killed the dude from
ap bio dad oh really seems like this
movie is better than a character split
up in a horror movie for no reason
cliche but here we are but seriously why
the wouldn't she go with him he's got
the fucking gun there were multiple
attackers got-damn this part of the
movie bothers me why is he wandering
around the barn with a flashlight
they had them surrounded in the house
just a couple minutes ago when exactly
did she think James or Kristen to run
down to the barn
this makes perfect sense to whisper here
when Kristen knows James is at the very
least 20 or 30 feet away from her this
movie answers the important question of
whatever happened to the unknown comic
Kristen takes off running as if she
knows that nothing interesting has
happened for three minutes Oh No Kristen
tripped over darkness the fuck are they
doing in there are the strangers busting
up some sheep in the house to kill some
time while they wait to kill some people
considering all these disappearing acts
this movie really only makes sense if
the killers are actually fucking ghosts
[Applause]
man between the axe and the door the
message scrawled on the windows and the
use of ham radio it's clear this movie
really wants to be the shining seriously
these people have a Casio keyboard
they're running around with set on
haunted house sound effects mode totally
get the screw is having fun hang around
with him but why wouldn't they have
already destroyed the radio they've been
in the barn so they knew it was there
and already cut the phone lines and
destroyed their cell phones weird The
Strangers content with the slashed tires
and busted windows setting the fire is
more likely to draw some unneeded
attention to this location than say not
setting a fire nobody can't even candle
right earlier in the movie they were
clearly only 2 but they've somehow
multiplied during the runtime also even
if this is in real time you're telling
me that in an hour they haven't burned
down any more than that or even gone out
considering how wide open the front door
is they just now thought to cut the
power isn't that one of the first steps
in the murder playbook ok there is no
way that ice cream is anywhere near
solid form at this point or a movie 101
lesson why you might not want to trap
yourself in an enclosed space such as a
fucking pantry when hiding from killers
damn for a guy with obvious respiratory
issues Baghead here's done a lot of
unnecessary running around tonight is
your home
scariest motive ever on film or lazy
screenwriting hmm don't worry Scott even
though this means you won't be in prey
at night there's always a spot for you
in 17 underworld sequels and even
clinging to life Liv Tyler is sexy as
hell is that wrong that's probably wrong
why did they stop to talk to
christianmingle.com in the first place
both of these kids probably had enough
of a look at doll face to create a
convincing police sketch when exactly
did the strangers take the time to put
the join and do some record back on the
last one they played was Merle Haggard
when Mike walked in I mean these kids
not freaked out in the slightest by all
this deadness like I know evangelicals
are weird and he's getting right up into
the bodies here with no visible effect
boobie ends on one last jump scare just
in case you made it all this way without
yourself
release the Beast boys let the killing
commence
[Music]
heythis I think I just figured something
out be the the fuck won't deny what the
Mexican firemen name is two kids Hosea
and hos be
[Music]
my clock on a Saturday